thank you just give me a second okay
works out good morning everyone
or maybe it's maybe kind of lunchtime
right now so I will rush through my talk
that you get to lunch very fast so yeah
welcome to my talk in person syndrome am
i suffering enough to talk about it
my name is milena Madoff rel and
front-end developer at nine elements in
Germany and authors of ojs organizer my
twitter handle is mega show you will
find it on the bottom of my slides at
first I have an important note for you
please keep in mind I'm not a
psychologist I will tell you how I
discovered the imposter syndrome for
myself and find a way to make it feel
less bad and maybe not every point will
fit for you but I hope the experiences I
made will help you to escape the bad
habits if you've got any questions
during my talk I will be here on both
days and you can also DM e on Twitter I
would like to tell you the story of my
life as short as possible my school was
pretty clear that I'm different to other
kids I read books in the breaks
I had a gossip wearing only black
clothes reading mangas and skateboarding
and so on and I was bullied for who I am
and what I am and I started to
questioning myself what is wrong with me
what did I wrong and I came to the
conclusion my behavior must be wrong
this is why no one likes me and I should
stop being the creep sitting in the
breaks on a bench while reading Harry
Potter I should stop skating and I
should stop being myself I tried to fit
in the role of the teenage girl but it
doesn't work out and I felt like a fraud
and faking my way through it and my time
at school was close to horrible and I
was happy when I lived at school but
when I started working it doesn't make a
huge difference for me I wasn't bullied
anymore which was kind of good I think
but I still was not a real part of the
group and why my colleagues went out for
after work party I was heading back home
we have some nice chats at the coffee
machine at work but I figured out that
we do not share any interests and again
I try to fill in and try to talk about
TV series where I only read the last
news about it so that I can talk about
it but it felt so wrong again and I
asked myself what's wrong with me after
a long journey and different jobs I
quitted
I started studying and within my time at
university I found the Open Text school
and joined the programming workshops the
open takes care is a nonprofit
organization who teaches people how to
code and in my case it was HTML CSS and
also JavaScript for beginners it was the
first time in my life that I belonged to
a group of people and they accepted me
for who I am and gave me a good feeling
about switching my careers and become a
front-end developer they told everyone
there you belong here and Here I am at
EJ's computer patch as a Defra and also
a front-end they'll work I'm very happy
that a lot of people from the open tech
school are still in my life since I'm a
front-end developer I get in touch with
awesome talented people and I was
thrilled about how fast you can learn
how to build a website with HTML and CSS
my love incur a learning curve was like
this you see the period of time and the
things I've learned and it was an
amazing feeling to learn so much in this
short period of time but after couple of
month it was like this the feeling
stepping on the same spot was horrible I
compared myself to the people I've met
and it feels like I'm absolutely stupid
it was hard to leave the comfort zone
and tasked with new program and stuff
overwhelmed me very fast and at least I
try to get tasks who were very easy for
me and I would things I have no idea of
gives me the feeling I have no idea what
I'm doing here and I do not belong here
I started to work harder on my own
skills when I came back from home I sat
down at my desk and try to solve the
programming problems I had during the
and my day was like eight hours of work
at work for up to six hours at work at
home and nightmares about work at night
and it doesn't work out and I just
talked about it with a friend of mine
and he was like what's wrong everything
is awesome you're doing a great job
you've achieved so much in this short
period of time and it feels like this
everyone is better than me I'm never
good enough and I'm overwhelmed I told
him but he still was like it's only in
your head stop worrying you're doing
great
I started researching where my doubts
are coming from and I just stumbled over
a book blog post about the impostor
syndrome and I was only scratching on
the surface what the impostor syndrome
is about and read a lot about it while
doing my research I found a lot of
multiple-choice tests and the most asked
questions were maybe you can ask
yourself right now if you would like to
that's everyone overestimates you hell
yes I get paid for a job and I think I
do not know enough about it to get paid
for it so yes everyone is overestimating
me so yes do you tend to discuss
yourself I was thinking about that and
every time I'm doing something new I'm
questioning is this the right thing
you're doing right now this the correct
path you go you're going right now it
was like yes of course the next thing is
you compare your ability to those around
you and think they are more intelligent
than you are as I mentioned I met a lot
of amazing talented and intelligent
people and I compare myself every time
to those and when it comes at work to
some coding discussions and I'm sitting
there like this oh my god what they are
right now I have no idea so yes I think
everyone else is more intelligent than
me that's the fear of failure freaks you
out hell yes
last week I organized the conference and
on Friday I heated by Coleman I was
terrified of fear well
this conference work out do I have
everything there what my speakers need
the attendants need and I was freaking
out so yes the fear of failure freaks me
the hell out of me
do you decline your own success yes one
more time my conference what
Sunday in the evening I was thinking
there have a have a cup of coffee and
everyone was like oh my god it was so
cool it was nice to meet you it was a
cool conference I was like I see what
went wrong so it was not that good as
you see as you say to me so yes I
declare my own use my own success
the next thing sometimes you afraid
others will discover how much knowledge
you really lack it's the same thing I
told you before when it come up to
calling discussions at work I should
shut my mouth because I'm afraid that
someone will tell me oh no no no you're
not right and that's lack of knowledge
so next point yes you are only
successful because you were on the right
time at the right place are you only
knew the right people yes of course I'm
only I could only stand here because I
met the people of the RTS of the open
tech school so absolutely you can't
understand the compliments you receive
hell yes that's the most annoying thing
I have got in my life I can't understand
some compliments I received I'm
discussing them the whole time and I
make me myself as tiny as I can so yes
you feel bad when you're not the best or
at least very special I have to think
about that again but it's not that worse
for me but at least I try to be the best
and I can get very angry of myself when
I'm not very special sometimes or I'm
not the best so yeah it works out for me
as well you avoid evaluations if
possible and have a dread of others
evaluations evaluating you evaluations
can be horrible especially when it came
to the point where I have to elevate if
evaluate other people and my opinion I'm
not skilled enough to
how people how good about that job was
so yes do you focus more on what you
haven't done I think yeah I'm
questioning myself again and again did I
organized everything as everything there
for my speakers this my talk right now
am I prepared for my talk right now so
I'm focusing I didn't do a dry run today
in the morning so why didn't I do that
and this is why what I was focusing on
and in the in the speaker room so yes
whoo 10 points to Gryffindor but well
now now I know that I'm suffering from
something I have no real idea about and
this was the time where I started to
take a deep dive and through the
imposter thing and I figured out why
reading all the blog posts and papers
what I'm doing to myself I sabotage
myself let that sink in I have immense
fear of failure but at the same time I'm
terrified of success and I want to prove
my worth but I worry I don't deserve the
success of compliments I receive and not
likely to ask for a race since I don't
see myself as competent I don't think
I'm worth more money so and people like
me to turn tend to work really hard as
mentioned before I said high standards
for myself and try my best to reach them
but no matter how much validation I
receive I've never felt competent too
long didn't listen it's the thinking
that makes me believe I'm actually
incompetent and intelligent and lazy I'm
convinced that I'm convinced that I'm
faking my way through my accomplishments
and it's the fear I will be exposed at
the fraud I believe I am when I figured
out all the things I started thinking
about how to stop it in my head
some people think I'm worth my money and
some people think that I belong here so
I could not be that bad I think so I
started researching again researching
assisting for me so while doing research
Alliance some techniques which helps me
to escape the bed zone and accept the
fact that it's not at worse as it seems
you will never be able
to get rid of it completely but it you
can make it feel less bad and before I
will talk about the techniques I
discovered over the time I would like to
show you a saying which describes why I
struggled so much in my life the reasons
we struggle with insecurity is because
we compare our behind the scenes with
everyone else's highlight reel this one
was right in the fields I was comparing
myself the whole time with other people
and when I read that quote I realized
that I was barking up the wrong tree
Facebook is the best example to see the
highlights real of everyone holiday
photos some nice dish then photos with
the significant other where everyone is
laughing and only have a great time and
you're sitting then ask yourself why do
they have such a awesome life and you're
sitting here on your desk and sobbing in
worries all the time now I've got the
quote in my in my phone in my notes and
when I'm thinking about that everyone
else is living a better life than me I
only read that it makes me feel better
and maybe it helps you too
so stop comparing yourself to others you
an individual and you're worth every
penny
or compliment you receive having idols
is a good thing but they are not you
they are not walking in your shoes and
they've made different experiences as
you and maybe they think that they are
frauds - you don't know you only see the
good Facebook post on social media and
you aren't born to live a life of
another person you as perfect as you are
next thing is everything is only in your
hat people who are working with you will
acknowledge your work they appreciate
you as the person who you are and they
will tell you when something went wrong
except the compliments you receive
because people are criticized faster
instead of praising you and imposes try
to be perfect when something is not
perfect it's not properly done right so
learn to be a healthy perfectionist most
things are done the product better than
effect and stop worrying excessively
about mistakes or setbacks sometimes you
have to ask yourself what would I do if
I was not afraid I asked myself in the
last few weeks would I ask my boss for a
raise
ask the cute person in front of me out
start a new project and there are a lot
of questions you can ask yourself like
in the same way when the fear kicks in
and if this doesn't work out for you ask
the right people to help you out with
your problem learn to ask for advice it
can be really hard in the beginning but
a lot of people are really happy to help
you out you don't have to prove that you
can solve every problem on your own
I started mentoring people in August and
September and at least I was a mentor at
two events right now and guess what
people will ask questions you cannot
answer and you cannot answer them but
that's good you don't know you don't
have to know everything Stack Overflow
or documentation can be your best
friends and it's a good thing to know
what you don't know is that's still not
enough to overcome the bad feelings talk
about it if you want to I'm helping
myself right now when I'm talking about
it maybe you're not into speaking to a
huge crowd like me right now but it
helps you to keep you aware that he was
suffering from something and especially
your friends can be really supportive
and help you out with your problem you
only have one thing to do bribe your
friends every time one of your friends
point out that you're under estimating
yourself spend them a cup of coffee or
maybe a beer but one thing I can tell
you it can be very expensive in the
beginning and maybe you should switch to
water and and some tea because your
friends will suffer from too much
caffeine or beer and with tea and water
they only have to pee a lot so that's
fine being wrong or not perfect doesn't
make you a fraud just keep in mind the
best circuit teams lose but
they are not frauds they know how to
kick the ball right oh there are many
million dollar companies that sometimes
fail as well evaluate the impact or what
could go wrong by asking yourself what's
the worst thing that can happen to me
right now this will help to elevate the
fear and the most things we're doing
happen I have not a huge impact
especially in tech we create software
for customers and maybe they are not
amused about a missed deadline but hey
we're humans not machines
we should start focusing on providing
value and write down your achievements
of the day this one is out of my
sketchbook at home and it's a smallest
for me from the last week I helped out
an elderly person to enter the tray to
enter the train I organized the
conference on my own I teach my
colleagues something I know I cooked a
really delicious meal for me and my
friends I denote a really good part of
code and this can be written down in a
diary only at a Google Doc it's up to
you where you write it down especially
the small things matter - like those
ones keep a file of nice things someone
was saying about you can you remember
the last time when you received a
compliment and know exactly the wording
no me neither
we forgotten too often the good parts in
life and this is why you should take
maybe screenshots and save them when
someone writes something good about you
make notes in your phone when someone
gives you an awesome compliment take a
look at it when you're feeling like a
fraud and what helps me the most stop
commenting compliments really just stop
it never do this again
just stop it I was a person who was
discussing my saw my other compliments
every time and it helped me a lot to
appreciate myself and the work I was
doing when I stopped commenting on
compliments if the sender a friendly
smile and say thank you for that and
before your thoughts start spinning take
a look at what you've done for the
person which gives you the compliment
ask yourself what the person give me a
compliment if my work was as bad as I
think yes answer is no in 99% and the
other 1% of people we would not like to
about the last thing is take time for
yourself if everything feels horrible
and me and you are freaking out on the
inside do what you enjoy the most for me
it's like taking a hot bath or grab a
good book have some quality time for
myself come down from the day and forget
for a short period of time the cold
feeling if you're freaking out in your
office maybe get a cup of tea take a
break do sit-ups tap the office dock
maybe whatever works out for you to calm
down let's start over with the good
parts of being an impostor and you think
maybe now wait what she was telling us
the whole time that she suffers from it
and now there are good parts of it
sometimes it's not that bad to suffer
from the imposter syndrome to be an
overachiever is not that bad at least we
try to be as perfect as possible and
everything we do so from time to time we
have to take a step back calm down and
live with the result which is maybe not
the perfect solution but if we can
accept it that we don't have to be
perfect that's not that bad to be an
overachiever do you know people who
think they are the best and everything
they doing and after a few sentences you
you talk to them you think they're not
the brightest candle on the cake those
people are in my opinion very annoying
and this is why I think when you
underestimate yourself from time to time
and promote it to the people it's not
that bad it's better to surprise the
people with what you've done and
achieved instead of disappointing them
with what they've expected from you
because you're overestimated yourself
maybe you're not suffering from the
imposter syndrome but after hearing the
symptoms you're asking yourself I think
a friend of mine is suffering from the
impostor syndrome what can I do
maybe someone tells you that they
feeling like a fraud faking everything
are they not good enough for the money
they get and you should not say hey I
was last week at the jeaious computer
just listen to a talk about the imposter
syndrome you ain't imposed to deal with
it don't do that to anyone they will
start researching like me and spend a
lot of time with it because the first
blog post I read had the title you the
imposter and I was like oh wow and the
worrying journey kicks in really badly
don't do that to anyone instead of
telling them that they are suffering
give them reasonable feedback maybe a
colleague of you is questioning
themselves the whole time and ask is
this okay what I'm doing or maybe can
you take a look at my code again please
and this more frequently than other
colleagues do take your time and explain
them that the work is good and
especially explain them the why maybe
the work is not perfect but you Kevin it
can tell them too that they can improve
here and there something but also with
the Y complimenting people only because
of the fears is not really helpful don't
compliment them only make only to make
them feel better explain them the why
you think like this and the why is the
most important thing but you can also
help them with if you talk about your
own fears if you feel uncomfortable with
it show the people that they are not
along with their problems maybe you're
working at a project and you've got a
deadline and every one of you knows
customers right they can get really
angry when you have to say oh my god no
in the end of the week it will not work
out we need one another week so and
there nope we pay for you so at least
deal with it in the end of the week of
the project have to be finished maybe
you can tell your colleague who may be
suffering from the impostor syndrome oh
my god deadline in the end of the week
of course I'm afraid something went
wrong when we deploy it to production
are you using a new framework maybe
react angular 1 Z J's whatever you can
say oh I've never done this before and
I'm also afraid of wool what will not
work out in the end
shall the people they do not have to
fight the battles alone to come to an
end with this talk I would like to show
you
beautiful phrase I heard while watching
Kung Fu Panda this phrase describes so
much how you escape the zone and what
you should focus on Okwe the turtle said
to the Panda you're too concerned with
what was and what will be there's the
saying yes there is yesterday's history
tomorrow's a mystery but today is a gift
that's why it's called the present if we
read over and over that saying thinks
getting less bad we are thinking the
whole time what we've done wrong and
maybe we can see the opportunities we
missed every day because of worrying
last but not least when we start over a
new job maybe ask ourselves was this the
right decision job offers do not cover
everything we are able to do contain
things we've never done but we are
applying for this job because every job
offers nearly the same right but there's
never be a perfect fit for everyone and
this is why I would like to say to you
to be an imposter is not the exception
it's a rule and everyone suffers from it
from time to time thank you
[Applause]
[Music]